all right turning to the war in Ukraine
Russia launched dozens of missiles this
morning at Targets across the country
but Ukraine says it shot most of them
down the Russians have also intensified
shelling in the southern city of Houston
recently liberated by Ukrainian forces
inly shows us how celebrations of
Victory there have become replaced by
fear and a rising number of Civilian
casualties
[Applause]
cranians celebrating Liberation from
Putin's control last month may have been
too much for the Russians the people of
Carson now pay a heavy price for their
freedom
on a daily basis Russian rockets and
artillery pound the city killing
ordinary people trying to reclaim their
lives life here is a rule of the dice
Victoria urusco was a Red Cross
volunteer she was killed steps away from
safety her mother shows the Medal of
Honor she was given I'm happy she helped
a lot of people she says Victoria was so
kind but it's painful for me now I must
be strong and raise her two children
nearby a Russian shell demolished the
house of Tamara brushen her son was
inside she scoured the wreckage looking
for his ID so she could reclaim his body
from the morgue why Russia shells her
son is hard to tell nothing they hit
appears to hold military value just
innocent civilians trying to survive
like this maternity hospital the first
strike hit outside nurses rushed the
pregnant women newborns and their
mothers to the basement the second
smashed into the building mercifully no
one was injured
it was frightening and unexpected this
new mother says the explosions just
begin and the window shattered my hands
are still shaking shattered like the
lives of so many ukrainians for CBS
mornings Ian Lee denipro Ukraine